The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: There's
some comments from the grader
who looked at your homeworks.
So a couple of
points to remember
that they seem to be sort of
pervasive in several homeworks.
One is that when
we do Snell's law,
we have to apply the
rule-- the rule goes
like n sine theta equals
n prime sine theta prime.
So remember that theta prime
is measured with respect
to the normal to the interface.
So if this line
is the interface,
I have, for example,
air and the glass here.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Oh.
AUDIENCE: Yes, that's good.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: I think
my hand is confusing it.
Maybe I should turn
off the autofocus.
OK.
So if this is the interface,
air and glass-- yes,
I think my hand
was confusing the--
and the ray is incident,
for example, like this,
then we apply Snell's law
with respect to the normal.
So this is the angle theta,
not this one out here,
not the other way around.
And for this one, of course,
the same goes to the other side
of the-- whoops--
the other side of the interface.
The ray would go in
kind of like this.
That would be theta prime.
So that was one comment
from the homeworks.
The other comment is about TIR.
TIR actually happens for
all angle of incidence
that are larger than
the critical angle.
There seemed to
be some confusion
that somehow TIR happens
only at the critical angle.
That is not true.
In fact, strictly speaking,
at exactly the critical angle,
TIR does not happen.
What does happen is
this surface wave
that I mentioned in the notes.
But for all angles
that are greater
than the critical angle,
this is when we have the TIR
condition for all those
angles, from critical
all the way to whatever it
is, 90 degrees, I suppose.
The third comment-- and,
actually, this is the last one.
The third comment is
about the speed of light.
Some of you-- and,
actually, this
is also in relation to
the streamer problem.
There was some confusion
where the speed of light
is proportional to the
index of refraction
or inversely proportional.
It is, in fact,
inversely proportional.
The speed of light
goes like c over n,
where n is the
index of refraction.
And I don't know if there's
a mnemonic for this,
but one way to
remember it is that c,
the speed of light in
vacuum, is the highest
speed that anything can have.
So, therefore, when
light enters a material,
it can only go slower.
So, then, the
index of refraction
tells you the amount by
which the speed of light
becomes slower in
a given dielectric.
So these are some
things that are
useful to keep in mind
as we move forward.
These two dots
don't mean anything.
Just the ink from
the markers that
penetrated the piece of
paper, so please ignore it.
So, last time, the topic was
composite optical elements.
So we started with an example
of two lenses, two thin lenses
that were in tandem, and we
did the imaging condition,
magnification, and all those
beautiful things with it.
And then we also looked
at the thin lens--
I'm sorry-- at the thick
lens, where the thickness is
defined--
as you recall, it
is defined relative
to the paraxial approximation.
If the distance between
the two curved surfaces
exceeds the cosine
theta, or whatever
it is that the paraxial
approximation limits
for the negligible distance,
then we call the lens thick.
And we saw that there's
some differences.
For example, the focal
length is a little bit
different in the
formula than it this
for the case of the thin lens.
But the primary
reason why we did it
is because I wanted
to define this concept
of principal planes.
So the principal planes--
I'll move slowly so the
camera can follow me.
So the principle planes
are basically the locations
where the rays bend at once.
So in a thick optical element,
whether it is a thick lens
or it is a composite of
several lenses in tandem,
as you can imagine, the rays
will bend several times.
They may bend up,
downs, straight,
and so on and so forth.
But the idea is that if you take
a parallel ray from infinity,
after however many times
it bends-- in this case,
it bends twice, once
here and once here--
eventually it comes out at
the final propagation angle.
So the principal
plane is the plane
that you obtain if you
extend the incoming ray,
you extend the outgoing ray,
and you find where they meet.
That is the principal plane.
In fact, in general, it
is a principal surface.
If you really do the geometry
right, it is not a plane.
It turns out to be
a curved surface,
but within a paraxial
approximation, it is a plane.
So that's why we define it with
sometimes as a principal plane
or as a principal surface.
I kind of try to stick
to the term principal
plane in the notes.
And then, relative to
the principal plane,
as we did last time, you can
define the various quantities.
The effective focal
length is simply
the distance from that principal
plane to the focal point.
So, basically, as
far as the rays that
are coming from the
left are concerned,
the principal plane is acting
like a thin lens, because the--
is acting like a thin
lens with a focal length
equal to the effective focal
length of the composite,
because this is the ray
coming from infinity.
And when it comes
out, it is as if I
had put a thin lens in
this particular location.
The opposite is true
for images at infinity.
So if you take a ray
from this point here,
it actually goes to the
first principal plane,
and then takes off to infinity.
Now, of course,
again, this is what
I get when I take the incoming
ray and the outgoing ray,
and then find where they meet.
In general, this ray also
suffers multiple refractions.
But if I take the first
one and the very last one,
then I can have a thin lens
at the first principal plane.
So this is the idea, and
we can see the reason
why they are
convenient when we do
the imaging condition for the
composite optical element.
So we'll not do this again.
Se Baek went through it
in great detail last time.
But you can see that,
basically, if we
know the principal
planes, then we
don't have to worry about the
rest of the physical system
any more, because we
can discover things
like imaging condition,
magnification,
and so on and so forth
simply by applying the rules
that we learned in the
case of the thin lens.
For example, in this case,
in order to find the image,
I take a ray that is horizontal.
Therefore, it would
have come from infinity.
I drag it all the way to
the second principal plane.
Then I know it has to
go through the focus.
And then I extend it further.
When I take another one that
goes through the first focus,
then I know that at the
first principal plane,
this ray will have to
become horizontal, and again
take off towards infinity.
So, therefore, this
ray goes like this.
And then where they
meet is actually
the location of the image.
So this is the idea.
And then all the rest of the
formulas about the imaging
distances, the magnifications,
lateral, angular, so on
and so forth, they all fall
out from the similar triangles
in this diagram,
just in the same way
we did them for the
thin lens, except now we
have these sort of additional
space between the two
principal planes.
So we have to be careful when
we deal with a ray that is
coming horizontal at the input.
It has to bend at the
second principal plane.
And when we think
the ray that goes
through the first focal point
and comes out horizontal,
that one has to go through
the first principal plane.
And the reason I'm
emphasizing this is because--
this is the generic case,
where the first principal is
to the left, the
second is to the right.
But there is optical
systems where
they may actually be swapped.
You may have the
second principal plane
to the left of the
first principal plane.
There's no rule
that forbids that.
It can happen.
So that's fine.
We still have to
apply the same rule,
but we have to be careful
where we bend the ray.
So one of the homeworks-- you
will see the homeworks that we
posted today and are due,
actually, next week--
you will see that this happens
in one of the optical systems
that we give you there.
The second principal plane
is actually to the left.
So I'll let you work
that out by yourselves,
but keep that in mind.
Always identify
which principal plane
you're using for any
given imaging condition.
Any questions about all of this?
Can someone say at
least good morning,
so I know if our sound
has been restored?
AUDIENCE: Hello,
hello, can you hear us?
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
OK, either nobody
wants to say good morning
or there's no sound.
AUDIENCE: No.
No sound, I guess.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: OK.
I'll keep going, and, hopefully,
some time at some point
we'll have sound.
Or at some time
you'll wake up enough
to be willing to
say good morning.
So, today, we'll
deal with a topic
called stops and apertures.
And, basically,
we'll spend the rest
of the hour learning the
meaning of all of these terms.
So there's quite a few of them--
aperture, pupil,
entrance, exit pupil.
And then we field stop, window,
entrance and exit, and so on.
So we'll spend some time
learning what these things are
and why they're useful
in an optical system.
So starting with the first
one, the aperture stop,
the aperture stop has
to do with the fact
that any optical instrument,
in practice, has a finite size.
Therefore-- OK, let me back up.
So the instrument
has a finite size.
But a point source, as
we learned, it actually--
at least an ideal source--
it emits kind of isotropically,
all the way 4 pi steradians
around the location
of the point source.
So what this means, then, is
that the optical instrument
can only capture a fraction
of the light that this--
that any given point
sources is emitting.
So the aperture
actually helps us
quantify how much is the light
that an optical instrument can
admit given the location
of a point source.
So it is defined, actually, with
respect to a point source that
is located at the
optical axis, that is,
at the center where
all of the optics
are rotationally
symmetric about.
And there's two concepts here.
One is the physical stop.
So the physical stop
is-- you can think of it
as the rim of the optics, the
physical limit beyond which
the rays that are
coming from the source,
they miss the optical
elements in the system.
Those of you who have
cameras, you're also
familiar with
physical stops that,
in relatively complicated
optical systems--
for example the lens that
goes with the camera--
inside there's a
little hole that
is very often adjustable
depending on the light level
and so on.
This hole, nowadays
automatically,
in the old days
with photographers
having manual control,
you would actually
open and close that opening
to admit more or less light.
This is called
the aperture stop.
And we also are familiar
with something else,
the pupil of our eyes.
If you look at someone's
eyes, there's a little hole.
And if you look in a
bright environment,
this hole is relatively small.
If you move to a
dark environment,
our eyes have a
mechanism that kind of
measures the ambient
light and opens up
or closes down the pupil.
So this is the aperture stop for
the optical system of our eye.
So the aperture stop, then,
is the physical element
that limits the acceptance
of the light rays.
So, in this case,
the aperture stop,
you can think of this sort
of black, thick line here,
you can think of it as
a physical, for example
a metal plate with a
hole in the center.
So that hole would be
the actual aperture stop
in this particular instrument.
The numerical aperture is
a mathematical quantity.
It is the angle subtended
from the point source
to the rim of the
physical aperture stop.
And I was a little bit sloppy
when I called the angle.
It is not the actual definition.
It's the sine of
that angle multiplied
by the index of refraction.
Now, we've already seen
Snell's law several times.
You can guess immediately
the reason people define
the numerical aperture this
way is so that this quantity is
conserved when you go through
flat refractive interfaces.
So it's very convenient because,
well, as we'll see later,
the numerical aperture is
a very important quantity
in characterizing
an optical system.
So, therefore, by sticking
the index of refraction
in this definition
here, we'll make sure
that the numerical
aperture is preserved
as rays go through various
elements in the system,
at least elements without power,
without optical power, that is,
as they go through
flat interfaces.
So that's the definition.
Now, of course, in
many optical systems,
the index where the
object lives is air.
So, therefore, n is 1.
And also, in this
class at least,
we deal with the
paraxial approximation,
where the sine of the
angle is approximately
equal to the angle itself.
So, therefore, indeed,
the numerical aperture
is approximately equal
to the angle itself.
However, as you have
seen from the homework,
if you already started it,
in many optical systems
the object lives in a
space of refractive index
different than 1.
For example, in
immersion microscopy,
we put a droplet of oil.
We drop a droplet of oil
on top of the sample.
Then we stick the
objective so that there
is oil in this space
here between the sample
and the objective.
Well, in that case,
we really should
include the index of
refraction in the definition
of the optic-- of the
numerical aperture.
So, of course, you
cannot speak yet,
but I do want to ask
a question myself now.
And if you can answer--
well, those of you
who can answer easily.
Those of you in Boston,
if you want to answer,
just please wave and we'll
figure out how to do it.
But the question
I wanted to ask,
what do you think the value
of the numerical aperture is?
Is it smaller than
1, bigger than 1?
What is it?
Do this if you think that
the numerical aperture is
bigger than 1.
Do this if you think that the
numerical aperture is always
less than 1.
What's the verdict?
Always less than 1.
Anybody who thinks the opposite,
that the numerical aperture can
be bigger than 1?
It's really strange.
I feel like we're transported
to a different century now
[INAUDIBLE].
Anyway.
So, actually, in principle--
and, in fact, people do it--
I can construct an
optical instrument
with a relatively
large acceptance angle.
For example, theta may be as
high as 75 degrees, 80 degrees.
It is not uncommon in high-end
microscope objective lenses
to have a very high
acceptance angle.
Of course, this would violate
the paraxial approximation,
but that is no problem.
The fact that the
instrument is not paraxial
actually does not make
it an invalid instrument,
so it's fine.
All it means is that our simple
theory here does not apply,
and we have to be more
sophisticated in the analysis,
but we can have a
large acceptance angle.
For example-- so, in that
case, the sine of this angle
may be close to 1,
maybe 0.9 or 0.95.
And, also, in addition, remember
that we can use immersion.
So we can put the object in a
liquid of index of refraction--
for example, if it is
water, that would be 1.3.
If it is one of
the immersion oils
that are used in microscopy,
what is the index, typically?
1.4, 1 point--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: Oh.
Just the same as glass?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: OK.
So even higher than for
immersion instruments, 1.54--
0.14.
I'm sorry.
1.514.
And so, in that case, if I
do 1.514 times 0.9, of course
it will be bigger than 1, right?
I don't know what it is,
but it would be definitely
bigger than 1.
So, actually, I can have
a numerical aperture
that is bigger than 1.
That is kind of a useful
point to remember.
Related to the-- so
the numerical aperture
is used very commonly
in microscopy
when we characterize
objective lenses.
Typically, we characterize them
by their numerical aperture.
In photography,
especially, people
prefer to use an alternate
quantity known as the f number.
So the f number is
kind of the inverse
of the numerical aperture
times a factor of 1/2,
which always confuses
the hell out of me.
But, anyway, the f number,
it is written like this.
And people replace the hash
symbol with the actual number.
For example, if you look
at the lens of a camera,
it may something like f/8.
This means that the f number
of this camera lens is 8.
So the rule of thumb is
where does your money go?
When you pay money for a
very good quality microscope
objective, one of those
that cost $10,000 or so,
typically you pay--
in a microscope
objective, you pay
for a large numerical aperture.
When you walk into
a store and you
buy a high-end, expensive
camera lens, one of those Nikon
or a Zeiss, really expensive
multi-element lenses
that look about as
big as my computer
here, what you pay there is
for a really low f number.
So, generally, large
numerical aperture is good.
Or, equivalently,
low f number is good,
provided you can
afford it, of course.
So, at the moment, the
way we defined it so far,
the numerical aperture, it
seems to be related only
to the energy acceptance
of the optical system, that
is, how much--
how many watts of optical power
the optical system admits.
So this is of course
important, but you
might wonder why am I
making such a big deal,
and why people pay so
much money for high NA.
Well, again, the energy
acceptance, as you can imagine,
is incredibly
important because it
will determine how many useful
photons from the object you
admit into your system
for imaging purposes.
But, as we will learn later,
the numerical aperture
also defines the resolution
of an optical system.
And, right now, you probably
know from everyday life
what resolution means.
People talk about the
resolution in your camera,
in your television,
and so on and so forth.
We will do a precise
definition of resolution
later, in about
a month from now.
We'll define it very
precisely, and we'll
see why and how it is related
to this numerical aperture
quantity.
But, again, the rule is that the
largest the numerical aperture,
or, equivalently, the
smaller the f number,
the better the resolution
of an optical system.
So we will see this
come up again and again.
So that's the basic
definition that we use.
Now, related to this
concept of aperture stop
and numeric aperture,
there is two sort
of derivative
definitions, and these
are called the pupils, the
entrance and exit pupils.
So in order to define
those, I kind of
need a multi-element
optical system,
so I sort of concocted
one over there.
I just made it up.
This is nothing in particular.
I just stuck some
lenses in tandem,
And i put the aperture stop
somewhere in the middle.
So think of this again as
a physical element, a hole
that I put in there.
So the reason we need these
additional definitions
of the pupils is that if
the aperture stop is varied
inside an optical instrument,
as it happens, for example,
in your camera
lens-- if you look
at your photographic camera
that you have at home,
you will see that the
aperture is varied
inside a relatively
large lens barrel
if you have a
sophisticated camera.
The aperture is a
physical element.
It is a hole, right?
So if you look at your
lens from the one side
that looks towards the object,
or from the opposite side that
looks towards the CCD,
you will see the aperture,
but you will not see
the aperture itself,
you will see the image
of that aperture stop
through the elements that
precede or succeed it.
So because of that, people
have defined this concept
of the entrance and exit pupil.
So the entrance
pupil is what you
get if you take
this aperture stop
and now you treat it as an
object in an imaging system,
and you image it through the
preceding optical elements.
Now, here, I've committed
a mortal violation.
I imaged from right to left.
We said last time
that every time we'll
write down an optical
system, the light
is assumed to go onwards
from left to right.
So, here, this is an exception.
When we deal with
aperture stops,
we actually image
from right to left,
because we really need to
look at this as the object,
and image it through the optical
elements that precede it.
So if we do that, then we
get the entrance pupil.
So, in this case, it would
look something like this.
So this is now not a
physical component any more.
It is the image of the
physical component that
was inside the
system, and we imaged
through the elements
that preceded it
in that optical system.
Similarly, we can
define the exit pupil
if we image the
physical aperture
stop through the
elements that succeed it.
So the two definitions
are kind of conjugate.
Now, with respect
to this entrance,
exit pupils and aperture
stops-- this is a mouthful--
you can define two
significant rays that
come up in the design of
optical systems all the time,
and we'll see why.
The first one is
called the chief ray,
and the chief ray is
defined as the ray that
goes through the center
of the aperture stop,
the physical aperture stop.
So that's one.
The other is called
the marginal ray,
and it is the ray that
goes through the rim
of the physical
aperture stop, that is,
the ray that just
clears the aperture.
If you take the
next ray, that would
propagate at a slightly higher
angle with respect to this one.
This ray would actually
hit the physical block
that is located at the
aperture plane and would miss.
So this last ray just
before the aperture stop
blocks the rest
of the light, this
is called the marginal ray.
So you can already see
the importance of this,
because the marginal ray
kind of defines again
the angle of acceptance
of the optical system.
Except, this time,
notice that I've
done this for an
off-axis object point.
Recall that a numerical
aperture, the way I
defined it before, it was
still the angle of acceptance
but for an on-axis object point.
Here, the marginal
and the chief rays,
I can define them for any
point I like, any point I
like that is in
the object space.
And this step, let me sort of--
OK, I already decided
that these rays help us
define the angle of acceptance.
Now, before I show
the next slide,
and since these two rays,
these two important rays,
where do you think they might
go with respect to the entrance
and exit pupils?
By definition, they go
through the center and edge
of the aperture
stop, respectively,
the chief and marginal ray.
So, therefore, with respect to
the entrance and exit pupils,
where do you think
these rays would pass?
So the answer is
that they should
pass through the
center and an edge,
respectively, as well,
because the entrance and exit
pupils are images of
the aperture stop.
So, for example,
if the chief ray
goes through the center
of the aperture stop,
then it should also go through
the center of the entrance
and exit pupils
because these are
images of the aperture
stop through the preceding
and succeeding elements.
And, similarly, the
marginal ray hits
the rim of the aperture stop.
Therefore, it should also
hit the rim of the entrance
and exit pupils, respectively.
Now, for the marginal
ray, there could
be magnifications involved.
So, for example, the distance
from the optical axis
to the rim, it may be different
in the aperture stop plane
than it is, for example, in
the entrance pupil plane.
And that is because,
in this case,
the optical system has
magnified the aperture stop.
So the entrance
pupil in this case
is bigger than the
physical stop itself.
So, therefore, the
marginal ray, it
hits the optical axis
at a different location.
And, also, as you can
see, there's an inversion.
It hits at the bottom
at the aperture stop,
and then it hits at the
top of the entrance pupil.
This is fine, but what I--
because of the way
optical systems behave.
They can produce inversions
and magnifications,
and as we have seen.
But what I want to
emphasize is that they
go through the rim
because of that property
that the aperture is imaged at
the entrance and exit pupils,
respectively.
And, of course, the
two rays will also
meet again at the corresponding
image point at the image plane.
Because the two rays emanated
from the object, if the imaging
system is good, that is, if
it does form an image properly
and we don't have some
kind of a weird defocus
or some other kind
of inconvenience,
then the two rays should better
meet again at the image point,
because the entire spherical
ray bundle that emanated here,
that diverged
here, it would also
converge by the time
it arrives here.
So, therefore, these
two rays are just
members of this
spherical ray bundle,
so they will meet again
at the object point.
So any questions?
I know this is frustrating.
Even if you have a question,
you cannot speak your mind.
But any questions?
Can you just wave at least
so I know to save time later
to answer the question?
AUDIENCE: So how do you define
the distance between the--
I guess he can't hear me.
Ah, right.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Let me move on
with a slightly
different concept,
and then we'll come back
to this topic again.
So the next topic
is a different kind
of stop called the field stop.
So remember the
definition of chief ray.
We said that the chief
ray is a ray that
goes through the
center of the pupil.
I mean the entrance pupil,
the aperture stop, and so on.
So here is a chief ray
from a tall object,
and here is a chief ray
from a short object.
| of the chief
rays, they will go
through the center of the
aperture stop by definition.
And, of course, they will
also go through the center
of the entrance pupil.
The entrance pupil used to
be here, if you remember.
I'm not drawing it
any more because I
don't want to
clutter this diagram,
but it used to be here.
So the two rays, they
meet at this point
because they're the
images of the aperture.
However, this ray
will go off axis
at other points in
the optical system,
and there will be some
point in the optical system
where one of these
rays may get cut.
This element in
the optical system
that limits the chief rays,
that element is called the field
stop.
And the physical significance
of the field stop
is actually very important
and even more intuitive
than the aperture stop.
The field stop is what
defines the field of view.
And now the field of view
has a formal definition.
It is this angle
here that I drew.
But even in colloquial language,
when we say the field of view,
we know exactly what we mean.
In an image, the field
of view is basically
the size that can be visible.
And outside the field of
view, the image is not formed.
So an example is if I look
at you-- well, actually,
this is great because I look
at you through a camera,
and the way the camera
is pointed right now,
I can only see the central row
of desks out in Cambridge but I
cannot see those of you
who are seated on the left
or on the right.
So you might be picking
your nose, for example,
and I would not
be able to see it.
And that's because you are
outside my field of view.
And thank you for the control,
for turning the camera.
Now what is happening, my
field of view is shifting.
So the field stop in
this case is actually
the dye, the electronic
dye that captures
the image electronically
on your side,
then transmits it to
us here in Singapore.
This is the physical field stop
that limits how many of you
I can see at any given instance.
So the field stop is second
to the numerical aperture
and the aperture stop,
is another very important
quantity.
It tells us how big is the size
of an object that we can see.
So if you look, for
example, at a telescope--
if you look at the night
sky through a telescope,
the field of view is basically
how many stars can fit,
what portion of the sky you
can fit within your image
when you look through
the telescope.
When you look through a
microscope, similarly, the size
of the specimen that you can
observe in the microscope,
that would be the field of view.
Now, intuitively, we would like
to define the field of view
in physical size, in meters,
or millimeters, or microns,
or whatever the case might be.
For reasons that will become
apparent a little bit later,
we prefer to define
the field of view
as an angle actually, the angle
subtended towards the object.
And you can guess--
I don't even have
to make you wait.
You can guess why we define
angle instead of physical size.
That is because, very
often, optical systems
have variable magnification.
So with the same optical
system might move a lens,
and then the object would
move, but the field of view
might not change.
So if I define it as a
size and then move it here,
then the size would be bigger,
whereas the angle generally
is preserved.
So that's why we define
the field of view
as an angle in radians
or degrees instead
of physical distances.
AUDIENCE: Hello, hello, hello.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS: So that is
the meaning of the field stop.
And, similarly, through the
entrance and exit pupils
that we saw for
the aperture stop,
we can define equivalent
quantities for the field stop,
but we'll call the windows.
So if we image the field stop
through the preceding elements,
we get what is called
the entrance window.
If we image it through
the succeeding elements,
we'll get what is
called the exit window.
And, generally, in an optical
system, these windows,
they should coincide with
your object and image planes
respectively.
So the entrance window should
coincide with the object plane.
The exit window should
coincide with the image plane.
If that's not the
case, there's something
wrong with the optical system.
It can happen.
It is not impossible,
but there's something
wrong with the optical system.
So now that we did that, let's
put all these definitions
together.
There's a lot of
confusion in the diagram,
but it shows everything.
It shows the chief
and marginal rays.
It shows the two physical
stops, the aperture stop
and the field stop.
And then it shows their
images with respect
to the preceding and
succeeding elements,
that are called the entrance
and exit pupil and windows,
respectively.
I realize this is a bunch of
terms that I threw at once.
So treat this as an
information session,
then go back and make sure you
read them again from the notes
and from the book so you make
sure they sort of solidify
in your mind.
But this diagram,
actually, I spent
a lot of time making this
diagram because I actually
drew it by hand.
Instead of using an
optical software,
I did it by hand, so it
took me a lot of time
to make it accurate.
But, to the best that I can--
I tried, it's pretty accurate,
except for this lens here.
This lens doesn't
look very good.
It's a negative lens.
It should have sort of diverged
this ray bundle even more.
If I had done this
properly, this
would then become monstrous,
so I didn't do it.
But, anyway.
But you can see how it works.
Here's the chief ray.
Let's trace it
through the system.
So here's the chief ray.
It goes through the center
of the entrance pupil.
Then it goes through the
edge of the field stops.
That means that I chose a chief
ray that propagates at an angle
equal to what?
Equal to the field
of view, right?
Because this is the last chief
ray admitted through a system.
If I put a chief ray at a bigger
angle, that is a taller object,
it would miss the field stop.
Then the same chief ray goes on.
It goes through a center
of the aperture stop
again, then again through
the center of the exit pupil,
and finally hits the edge
of the exit window, which
is also the tip of the image.
That's the chief ray.
Now let's go through
the marginal ray.
The marginal ray will hit the
rim of the entrance pupil,
then will hit the rim
of the field stop again.
Why?
I'll give you 30 seconds
to think about it.
Why does the marginal ray
hit the rim of the field stop
again?
My computer has
actually a timer,
so I can count the 30
seconds very precisely.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
Oh, there is audio,
so you can even
speak your mind now.
Thanks, by the way, for--
thanks, control, for fixing it.
Anybody?
Why does the marginal ray
also go through the rim,
the edge of the field stop?
AUDIENCE: Because
the entrance window
is an image of the field stop?
Or it's the other way around.
So the marginal ray is--
I mean, it's the edge
of window, so it's
going to be on the edge
of the field stop also.
GEORGE BARBASTATHIS:
That's exactly right.
These two planes are
images of each other.
So since the marginal ray
meets the chief ray here,
then it should also meet
the chief ray here again.
Another way to put it
is that this is actually
an intermediate image plane for
this particular optical system.
So then the-- in
other words, you
would see an image of
the object itself here
if you were to stick your eye.
Then the imaginary
ray will go again.
Now it goes again through
the edge of the aperture stop
again.
And that is, of
course, because it
went through the
edge of the pupil,
and since the pupil
and the aperture stop
are images of each other, then
it has to go through the edge
again.
Now it will become repetitive.
It will hit again the rim of the
exit pupil for the same reason.
And then, finally, it would
hit the edge of the exit window
because the exit window is
an image of the field stop.
So these multiple
imaging requirements,
they sort of make this
all makes sense, right?
But this is how they work.
The marginal ray, as
the name suggests,
hits the rims of everything--
the aperture stops, the pupils,
the windows, and all that.
The chief ray, it goes
through the center
of the pupils, entrance and
exit, and the aperture stop,
and hits the edges, the
rims of the field stop
and the associated
entrance and exit windows.
And, finally, now that we
have everything together, here
is again the definition
of the field of view.
It is angle between the
last two chief rays admitted
by the system, last
two meaning that it
is the last two that the
field stop would admit.
And the numerical
aperture is the angle
between the two marginal rays
that depart from the center,
from the center of
the window, that is,
from the optical axis itself.
We do not define the numerical
aperture from off-axis points.
The reason is that, in poorly
designed optical systems--
first of all, let me say,
in an ideal optical system,
the numerical aperture should be
equal no matter where you are.
Within the field of view,
the numerical aperture
should be the same.
In practice, that is
very difficult to do,
and if you do a particularly
poor job as a designer,
the numerical aperture
can decrease drastically
when you go off axis here.
In fact, in the next
example that I will show,
this will happen.
The numerical aperture
becomes drastically smaller
as you go off axis.
That is called vignetting.
It's one of those French words
that have crept in optics
and is difficult to pronounce.
You will see it
written in a second.
I will just write it
down here, vignetting.
It is very annoying, because
if you have vignetting
in an optical system, then
the edges of the image,
they appear darker.
Remember, the numerical
aperture is the amount of light
that the optical system admits.
Well, if I admit more
light in the center,
I have a larger numerical
aperture in the center.
A numerical aperture
decreases as I go off axis,
it means that the edges of
the image will be darker.
It will be dimmer.
And that is, of course,
very undesirable.
And, generally, when we design
microscopes, telescopes,
and such, we try to make sure
that this will not happen.
But, anyway, because
this could happen,
that's why the numerical
aperture is defined
at the center, on
axis, so that it
has an unambiguous definition.
So having said all
that, let's look now
at an example that
will actually reveal
this vignetting phenomenon,
in addition to other things.
So this example is
relatively simple.
It is just a single thin lens.
And then, in front
of the thin lens,
we've put an aperture stop.
You can think of
it-- actually, this
is a very simplified model
of the eye, of the human eye.
We have a lens in front of it.
In the human eye, we
call it the pupil, right?
Of course, in the
human eye, in actuality
you also have an
additional lens in front
of the pupil called the cornea.
But, anyway, that's why this
is perhaps not an ideal model.
But, anyway, that's the
example that I chose to do.
And, in addition, it
has a field stop which
is located at the image plane.
Now, generally, if you see
a stop at the image plane,
this is a good candidate to
be the field stop, right.
Because, clearly, if I image
anything outside this opening--
this is what aperture
means, by the way.
Literally, aperture
means opening.
So if I image anything
outside this opening,
then it will hit the block, and
therefore it will not be image.
So, therefore, this is very
clearly the field stop.
Physically, the field
stop is, for example,
as I mentioned
earlier, it is the size
of the chip that registers
the digital image, right?
It's a very simple
instance of a field stop.
In old-fashioned
cameras that use film,
then the field stop would be,
in that case, the film itself.
Wherever the film is
chemically active,
this is where you
record the image.
Outside, it's just lost.
Whatever is imaged
outside that area is lost.
So, in this case, it is pretty
clear who is the aperture
and who is the field stop.
So you can see very clearly
that if you take an object
point on the axis, then
the physical aperture here
will block the
angle of acceptance
from this particular point.
And, therefore, this
is the aperture stop.
And, also, because there
is no elements to the left,
this is also the entrance pupil.
If there is no element to image
it through, the aperture stop
will also be, simultaneously,
the entrance pupil.
What this means is that if you
look at the imaging instrument,
you will actually see the
pupil itself before you ever
see anything else.
So that's why the two
things are actually
coincident in this case.
What about the exit pupil?
Well, the exit pupil is
what I will see on this side
if I image this element through
the succeeding elements.
So the succeeding element
is this lens here.
So what will I see if I
image this through the lens?
Well, this element now--
forget about the actual object
of the system.
When we question-- when we ask
what are the entrance and exit
pupils, this is now our object.
We're trying to see where
this would be imaged
through the optical system.
And we notice is that this
is between the focal point
and the lens.
Here's the focal point.
Here's the lens.
This is in between.
Therefore, this will
form a virtual image.
So the exit pupil would
be somewhere out here.
It would be actually to
the left of the lens.
That is not surprising.
All it means is that
if I go here and then
look at the optical instrument
this way, what I will see,
I will see a virtual
image of the pupil,
very similar to
the virtual images
that you saw last time
in the demo in the class
when Pepe brought the
magnifier objective.
So that's the exit
pupil over here.
And what about the
marginal and chief rays?
Well, here is the--
here they are.
Here's the marginal ray.
Here's the chief ray.
The chief ray, by
definition, has
to go out through the
center of the aperture stop.
So that is indeed.
The marginal ray hits the rim.
And what about
the field of view?
Well, the field of view will
be defined by the pupil--
I'm sorry.
It would be defined
by the field stop.
Now, notice that the field
stop is also the exit window
because there is no optical
elements to its right.
So, therefore, that
is the exit window.
The entrance window is
at the object plane,
since this is the
object plane and this
is the image plane that
satisfy an imaging condition.
That is, if you image the field
stop through the preceding
optical elements,
you'll arrive here.
So that's the entrance window.
And, of course,
the field of view
is defined by the two chief rays
that just clear the field stop,
so here they are.
And the angle between the
two is the field of view.
By the way, there is one
ambiguity in the literature.
Some people define the field
of view as the full angle.
Some people define
it as the half angle.
It's a matter of taste,
how you want to define it.
But just make sure you tell
people what you really mean,
if you really mean
the full thing or not.
And here they're all together,
all these quantities.
And-- yes?
Oh, let me ask--
yes, never mind.
And, in this case, I
actually worked out the math.
I will not go through it here.
I will let you do
it by yourselves.
If I put some
symbols, for example
if I call the size of the
aperture stop, I call it a.
The size of the field
stop, I call it w prime.
Then I have distance z between
the aperture stop and the lens,
distance s prime between
the lens and the field stop.
And then this calculation
shows you where--
how you find the other
elements of the system.
For example, when it comes
to the entrance pupil,
what should you to do?
Well, for the entrance
pupil, we have
to consider this optical system.
If that's our aperture stop,
then I have distance z.
Then I have the lens.
And then-- well, I'm sorry.
The entrance pupil is the--
I should have said
the exit pupil.
So where is the exit pupil?
Well I have to image
this aperture stop
through the system.
So how do I image it?
Well, let's say that the exit
pupil is at some distance z
prime to the right of the lens.
Well, how do we find z prime?
We apply the imaging condition,
1 over z plus 1 over z prime
equals 1 over f.
We can solve that.
1 over z prime equals 1
over f minus 1 over z.
This is also known as z
minus f over f times z.
Or z prime equals f
times z over z minus f.
Now, I said that
the aperture stop
is between the focal
point and the lens.
That means that z is
less than f in this case.
Therefore, this quantity--
since z is less than f,
this quantity turned
out to be negative.
If it is negative, it
means that my assumption
before that the exit pupil is
to the right was incorrect.
My assumption would
have been correct
if z prime had turned out
to be a positive quantity.
Since this is turning
out to be negative here,
it means that the actual
exit pupil is to the right.
I'm sorry.
It is to the left, opposite
from my assumption.
So, therefore, the exit pupil
is over here, as I already said,
or as I already said before.
And, basically,
this result, these
are all the quantities here.
You can see the marginal
ray from the field edge,
the marginal ray from
on axis, the chief ray,
and so on and so forth.
And the last comment
here, I did not really
prove it mathematically.
You can do it if you like.
It's a bit of a more
involved calculation.
But even visually
here, you can see
that the angle between
marginal rays on axis
is, even in my
handwritten diagram here,
it is visibly larger than
the angle between the two
marginal rays off axis.
This means that this
particular system here
is subject to vignetting
that I mentioned earlier.
That's the term
here, vignetting,
which means it is not a very
well-designed optical system.
In sophisticated
optical systems,
there's rules that we follow
in order to avoid vignetting.
When I describe the
microscope next week--
I mean, not next week.
Next Wednesday, in
2 days from today,
I will show you how
microscopes are designed
in order to avoid vignetting.
And I see that I've already
gone 2 minutes over time.
So let me conclude,
unless there's
any questions that someone will
ask, now that we have sound.